in 1995 I was in Paris and at that time
CMU had a really great reputation was
probably both to do to robotics and
computer science and engineering and in
addition Pittsburgh at that time was
most livable city and it is too so I
think this were main attractions not
only for me but also for my family
what were my dreams when I came to CMU
this was as I mentioned 24 years ago so
many things didn't exist you know you we
didn't have a fancy I phones or iPods or
you know digital cameras and many others
so I think that it 24 years is a quarter
century it's a really time that
sometimes dreams who are born during the
time I was here and I think but this is
really what has to be done but you you
adjust yourself in some sense to
whatever challenges are facing our
society and you you learn things and you
try to solve them tomorrow so you know
what we do we do polymer science polymer
chemistry or polymer synthesis and in
order to understand it a little better
you have to realize the importance of
polymers in some sense so polymers are
part of us we are in fact 80% of water
and whereas these polymers proteins
nucleic acids or carbohydrates and
polymers are everywhere so synthetic
polymers will be plastics rubbers fibers
very thin films and maneuvers so in fact
what we do we do ethical polymerization
and this is a process which makes
approximately 50% of all polymers it's a
very in fact difficult to be controlled
process because the polymer chains
it grows within a one-second time and it
adds monomer units so like small parts
to chain within a frequency of 1 milli
second dollars and then after 1 second
this change died but sometimes they can
also transfer so they have offspring in
some sense and the problem is that this
life of propagating chain is
one second so it behaves nearly like
human being because it grows it was born
and then it dies but this happens at a
time which is hundred million times
faster and then our lifetime so it's
very difficult to be controlled so what
we do very often we try to extend this
one second life to something like a day
or maybe a couple hours and this is
really a challenge in how to do it so we
take this one second life of propagated
shine and then chop it down thousand
pieces one millisecond each and insert
one minute time in between every one
millisecond so it's one second is
thousand milliseconds plus thousand
minutes so it's a day modest so of
course if you do that you have to
understand somehow what to do it with
your catalyst how much this catalyst how
little these catalysts and one of the
recent advances which we did was really
reducing the amount of catalyst by a
factor of thousands so essentially parts
per million any other catalyst and using
some environmentally friendly reducing
agent like by time you see us carbon
acid things like that so this is one
part of what we do the other one is
really engineering macromolecule of this
polymer chain making them with different
shapes stars sometimes complex
structures sometimes very specific
self-organizing molecules so this is
really something which allows to these
chains which are made by by our group
essentially by many of our colleagues in
the world to self-assembly to some nano
structured morphology so this is really
enabling in some sense nanotechnology
but there are also many potential
applications for polymers will become
may be intelligent or smart which can
respond to environment which can
contract or expand which can toughen or
sometimes get harder or softer and
eventually it can go even to some
interactive materials so materials which
will be potentially functioning but
function in a very responsive and
interactive way it may be like drug
deliveries which would be target in
particular part but also delivering drug
only when it is needed on a demand in
some sense when our organ is
would need that so I think that this is
probably what what we try to do is is to
make them on one side less expensively
but also more precisely and aiming at
some new potential applications as well
so I I think that you cannot plan the
research you cannot plan inventions I
mean sometimes you have a dream at night
that's 2:00 a.m. or 3:00 a.m. and you
know just you you have to be obsessed in
some sense with it but at the same time
you have to have a passion and I think
things which I try to teach my students
my goal but I have to be really
passionate about what they do and if I
do then they have a very good feedback
and it's really boost of activity and
increases both productivity and were
activities